okay for people joining this live stream
we are talking about various sound and
vision
audio and video functionality for
upcoming version of
language um
and uh let's see where are we starting
here
we had already done some of this but
let's uh
what can we um um
uh please please tell me where to start
should we should maybe look at import
export for a minute first
yeah we didn't look at that at all right
let's let's start with that and then
let's go back loop back to the
further discussion of the audio video
stuff make sense
great
some updates in the afternoon examples
and stuff
um
let these run okay so let's start
talking through this
okay so some of these uh okay these are
just
um element types metadata and so on
right
yes yeah so we're going to have an
obsolete page
we're going to have an obsolete format
page for these things pointing to the
other
other versions yes correct yes okay
that's a new thing to have obsolete
format pages right
yes okay they're already in
if you want to look at them i don't
think i need to i mean
okay uh where am i starting here pdf
pdf new
so i have to go those other other
formats
get format page pdf new
okay what's the main thing i'm looking
at here the excluded note
summarizes all that's coming
this note here the preacherized piece or
this thing here no
the excluded note okay
29 elements more metadata more robust
and complete embedded images
so you're saying if i take a random
paper from archive or something i will
get something reasonable imported is
that what you're telling me
yes can i try it yes
okay so i'm trying it on the prototype
build
yeah i think one new thing it was
that what was there was not you know in
the current
version of pdf at all vector graphics
we rely on our previous vector graphics
in this new converter as well
but we're positive we can get updated
vector graphics in 12 2 as well
i'm sorry updated vector graphics as in
what do you mean by
vector graphics there so pdf
yeah pdf used to get imported as
graphics
as vector graphics and we are defaulting
now
to images because we we haven't updated
graphics
which we called pages element before
i'm saying we are positive we can update
that as well in the timeline for 12
2. if we don't we still rely on whatever
we had before
for vector graphics but we are
defaulting to the image element
which is rasterizing the pages okay so
i'm going to import a random
paper that i just found uh
so i could just say here import
of the span and paper comma what do i
say pdf new uh no
just say just that will give you a set
of rasterized images
yep
oh that's quite nice did that work
before
we had a very large failure rate before
that's really nice yep
okay now what else can i do plain text
table of contents which is called
content
contents graph embedded images
attachments
okay hold on hold on so if i say plain
text here
that's nice and it's quite zippy too
[Laughter]
i thought it was postscript first i
thought it was sort of you know the
underlying postscript first but it
wasn't
it's it's the math yeah
yeah sorry what else can i say uh plain
test text list
is gonna chunk this up into different
pages so you'll get a list of
strings do we want to say plain text
list or plain text pages
either one and you can ask for just one
page
in a list say plain text list or i think
we should call it plain text pages
okay um
uh brian on our live stream is asking
how well does the plain text work with
pdf documents with multiple columns
it all depends on how it's layout laid
out in the pdf itself
if it is laid out so that the first
column is first
we're going to get it correct if if it's
not
pdf is very wild and what can be stored
in it
it's just going to go in the sequence
that content is stored in the pdf
do you think it should be plain text
pages rather than plain text lists i
think it'll be slightly clearer
um then do we want image pages instead
of image list
no all right leave it as plain text list
so what so if i say image list here
what is this that's the default to what
you just got
oh okay okay fine so what are the other
things i can ask for
um with this one i don't see embedded
images or attachments
but those are also um
images how do i ask for embedded images
just ask for embedded images as as an
element but i don't see oh i see one
image there
embedded images like that yes
no okay attachments maybe this is store
there's an attachment
yeah i'm sure and the table of contents
how did that work
contents graph gives you a graph object
that's funky
what the heck is this a graph object
like oh yeah that was bad
um what the hell is that
this is a graph object with specified uh
vertex edge styles that are not
shown and where it takes placement that
kind of looks like
um a table
so if i do if i do vertex list or write
vertex list or
vertex count and things like that it
works you can traverse that tree however
you want
it's cool
i don't know what was id by the way id
is surely i
capital i capital d sure
right various people on the live stream
are pointing out that what you're
calling image lists should really be
called page images
because that's what it is
okay okay so if that's called page
images
and that would go with embedded images i
like that right
page images and embedded images so then
plain text list you want plain text
pages or no page plain
text you said i would think the
consistent thing will be pages plain
text
plain text will be the the whole plain
text
and then pages plain text with the one
on a page by page basis
okay
um and then page images or pages image
no no page images images yep okay
page images
oh i see pet page page images page
okay i agree page plain text page images
how do we deal with this um
what should we call this
page texts i don't like that very much
well i could go with plain text list for
this
i'm not sure roger do you have an
opinion
yeah i think plain text
no no no we're asking this case the case
no i got a text i'm just thinking i'm
thinking okay
okay if we're not using list anywhere
else it
feels a little plain text pages
yeah it's a little weird because page
images and plain text pages
i know
page plain text instead of pages
plain text english wise it seems very
weird
page text page
plain text that's weird going with this
look i think given little auto complete
he says
pay whoops planes pages plain textures
um yeah uh
peltieri on our live stream suggesting
textual pages but
that's not going to that would again
have the word pages at the end
oh gosh i don't know it's a minor thing
but we might as well get it right
next
let's say page is plain text okay
all right uh this is wonderful it's
really cool
one one other probably important new
thing that is coming
is form fields where you have forms
that you could have hundreds of forms
that are filled you can get the raw form
without all the fillings
or you could get the fillings as well
you could get highlights you could get
these are i think gonna be great for um
automated analysis of yeah okay so so
look you've got a bunch of these things
here which are render that's a weird
option name
[Music]
this is specifically for that do we want
to render
the highlights the annotations form
fields and stuff when we
import as an image or do we want to
remove or not include all of those
see the settings for render could be a
list of
annotations and form fields
don't we have a thing some kind of
option there's rendering something or
other
look at that we have a thing called
rendering options what do you know
that's a little weird to use but not
completely crazy
what do you think that the name is not
crazy at all but the ref page would have
to be completely redone
and all of these settings should be
moved to style and
cell and related functions
yeah well okay but i don't think render
no but i i don't think steven meant that
that should be rendering options that's
it's
totally different i i don't think yeah
well that's just what the use of render
that was right render
but but i mean so
we do have include something
but this really is rendered elements
arrow annotations form fields all right
i like that
yes yeah yes it is
okay all right fine a question from
brian on a live stream what is the
definition of plain text
utf-8 or ascii or what
um we don't have character encoding or
anything
here um i don't know what we imported
that we probably should think about that
we should think about the character
probably have to think about that
yep um that's a good thought
what's good you know benchmark charlie
do we have even um
do we have any sort of um like cyrillic
pdfs or something like we do
yes okay
yeah sandra on livestream is pointing
out the rendering options could be like
method totally different for each
function i agree i think that's sort of
the future
um and something we should think about
but i don't think we have to cross that
bridge specifically for pdf import i'm
very excited that we have pdf import now
this is great
um what happens if i say if i take this
innate and i say image trim is that
going to do what i expect
image crop you mean do you want to get
i want to get the the area that i care
about
oh wow that's so cool
great and now
what is the rendering uh we rendered
this right so what is our rendering
resolution
um could be specified as a raster size
we should we absolutely should one thing
we discussed just earlier today
is to get the page size and um
and rasterize at the specified page size
in the pdf
but already you should be able to save
sorry what is that this is
okay it's not bad not bad at all
um except for the amplitude yeah
yeah um
okay sorry what are you saying about
raster size here we we can specify
basically you can specify the raster
size at the import level
and your resolution will be higher what
whatever size pixel dimensions you
specify
okay okay but we also probably want them
as resolution don't we
we can do that as well yes i think we
should do that both of those should be
it's going to be similar to rasterize
you can specify
either at the resolution or raster yeah
it should be just like rasterize
yep
um brian is asking what kind of metadata
is accessible from pdf
apparently image resolution is already
supported as well
okay so so what what kind of metadata is
that here
for which one i think the question is
no no there's a different question about
mp3 but for pdf
for pdf um it's already on your page
things like author creation date creator
keywords and so forth
where where i don't see it on the top of
your page
that first table okay so how do i get
that how do i get
all the metadata um
i think when meta information
information is grouped we are
introducing a meta information element
which gives an association of all
metadata
we haven't done it call it metadata why
don't we just call the thing
i would love to do that rename we have
an option
called meta information as well i know
that i know that but let's leave that
for now
i think we put that in there because
we're not but i think we should support
metadata here that just provides an
association
of all metadata elements okay okay
just this an association of these these
creatures here
okay should we propagate that to all to
many other formats
i think so i think so and i think we
should review the possibility of
changing
the meta information thing to support
you know to be metadata
okay all right that was a piece of good
news with pdf
okay can we go back okay we're going to
go down the rest of this list
quickly on mp3 metadata id3 is
supported already i guess it was
supported
a few versions ago so okay all right
fine
um okay moving down here updated export
what what's what's updated about do i do
i need to look at this what's updated
about that not necessarily it just works
now
smooth and grey so if i take
if i take my random universe model i can
update i can export it as dicom is that
right yep
yep so i mean if i if i take for example
if i say
something like um uh what's a good
what's a good surface that i can easily
get
um trivially would get some surface
i don't know um
[Music]
uh name a surface guys
roger name a surface somebody else here
i don't know boy a boy surface
there's a boy or boy's surface
oh for goodness sake
now what do you expect from this to be
exported into the dicom
it's not going to be a sliced 3d
volume stored in the dicom it's going to
be the rasterized version of that okay
but if i say export to dicom of this
file file comma dot com
yeah i don't think i have a dicom
register isn't very useful
but you're saying i will get a bone
that's this shape is that correct
the rasterized a bone that is a
rasterized version of this shape
yes cool okay what is heif
it's the format that is very
widely used now by phones um apple
and other formats it's the dot hake
typically exactly the one thing that's
interesting
is that it actually
um yeah it stores it it has a depth
image
oh yeah because i guess i knew that
so and also
we were talking about is it like an
alpha channel is the is the depth like
an alpha channel
it's a single um it's a scalar value
chan
image yes it but it's not quite the
alpha channel
you don't use it as you do you use alpha
channel
it it's really an estimate of how far
pixels are in the image what unit
um actually i don't know
i think it depends on how the
reconstruction happens on on different
phones it's
not a zero to one scale too so if i
simply upload
my if i send myself email if i take a
picture and i send myself email
what will it be by default
an hdif file or what it depends on your
phone settings as well
for sharing purposes you can say you
want to send jpeg or you want to say
high efficient format i see
so so in other words if i take a picture
i could get a depth map
from my just my my regular iphone
cool by the way we should have a
workflow that explains how to do that
sure the other thing that's interesting
that
these ones have basically little
animations they take a sequence of
images yeah i know
right can we get those yeah so we're
thinking that we should if we introduce
the animation object
the animated image object that we were
going to talk about above
here yep then we could import those as
animated images
that would be wonderful excellent idea
now the interesting thing about hafe is
that it can also include an audio track
um which then i guess
we have to import as a video object that
could have an audio track as well
because any or
or maybe our animated image could be
capable of storing audio
one of the two but
no we have i guess i have seen this
spelling well i mean
don't we can you check elsewhere that we
we're doing it with
mixed case okay depth image here so
can i export a depth image as well
we don't have export of hey fedo once we
have it yes
okay what what are these things here um
additional elements around
depth image it's typically smaller size
than the original image that is stored
so it would be useful to get the image
size of that
don't we how would we then how would we
sort of
map it on to it's typically resized
okay but maybe we want to be able to
return an element which is the combined
depth you know depth image at the
correct
size so i see composite it with an as an
alpha channel or even as an alpha
channel um well you have once also
proposed something like a depth
um depth included image object
that's that's what you said as well i'm
i'm suggesting we wait on that
and we experiment with um importing that
image
separately working with it until we
produce a full on
try new object but i agree with you that
the same size depth image might be a
useful element to import
fine but yeah maybe with some
option like raster size full or all
well where's the raster size going
because that's that's if it's just you
don't want to be importing twice
i would say you would resize right i
would i would just call it depth image
resized or something
uh-huh okay
okay although that suggests that it's
been resized because i wouldn't have
guessed that the depth image was not
the same size as the original image
so maybe depth image should be this
i see otherwise we could do depth
image that is the full size and
depth image original size or something
i don't know what's more useful
examples that we have recall we have
examples in net repository where
we estimate the depth you typically want
to list
this plot 3d the surface so many points
are going to be
too much for visualization as well so in
a sense the smaller resolution is
good okay so depth image full size might
be a reasonable way to do it
okay lower case s or upper case
i think lower case but i'm not sure
they're two separate words so you want
to be hyphenated in this situation so
grammatically speaking it would make
sense to be upper case
all right okay
um comments from our live stream sanders
says you can do video
live photos on iphones yes that's what
we're talking about
um how would we access the depth info
in a hyph image do we have to tear apart
the pixels manually is there an easy way
to strip out the depth info that's what
this is suggesting
that if you import the element depth
image you will just get the depth data
mm-hmm um
let's see what about importing ali asks
what about importing tiff image stacks
xy time or xyz time that have two or
more channels worth of time
it's pretty common data for bioimaging
and microscopy he says
let's say we do have multi-frame tiffs
um if that's what limits
yeah that then we have it it just comes
back if time is different frames okay
that that's what we have already do we
call the manage stacks because i've
certainly heard them called image stacks
do we have that as a documentation word
no we well as a keyword yes i can
i can check but as an element we call it
image list
there i see well let's just make sure
that there's nothing
about tagging for example a metadata tag
for these sub elements for that
stack
okay excuse me okay
[Applause]
xmp metadata import improvement do i
need to look at this is this is this
going to
get some wild story of different weird
metadata
fields not no yes altitude gps
longitude gps latitude gps date time
okay fine those were standard ones in
exif they're they're all very typical
and common
xmp on the other side is can be very
wild but we
contain all of them in on their xmp i
see
okay fine okay
emf and wmf isn't
emf some something to do with them
with with eeg and or something what is
that
no no no no no it's a it's windows
system format
it's an expanded version of wmf okay so
these are
we're killing both of these yeah um
that's
that's not ours but they are uh image
formats front end is
dropping them from export packet no way
they're gonna contain
continuous that's flash that is flash
and flash player is going to go obsolete
as of
end of 2020.
okay so what's your point i mean why why
shouldn't we continue to be able to
import flash
i i think it's the point is that we're
gonna continue
um having the capability we're again
marking the pages as obsolete to suggest
that we're not maintaining
these anymore i wouldn't and it's i
would i would not do that if flash is
frozen
flash will go on being able to import
flash and it's useful there'll be flash
around for millions of years
i wouldn't mark it as obsolete why would
we market as obsolete
if the format is frozen our code is
going to keep working
almost certainly i i think the most
useful thing here is to say
is to even recommend people to convert
their flash files into something like
mp4 you can say that
but you could okay we can have a new
weird kind of stripe
if you're using this kind of file you
probably don't want to go on using it
but it's not the page is obsolete
because flash that was created 20 years
ago we still want to be able to import
see what i'm saying importer for swf
we never had we're not getting it
through both of these were export only
formats
okay fine okay then i obsolete them
yes i agree however
flv we can now import through ffmpeg
and i'm i'm suggesting the very first
example is that if you have
flv just convert it to mp4
fine so i wouldn't obsolete flv then i
would only obsolete swf and obs
and say now the importer the importer is
coming through
video format which is a catch-all um
registered format i understand but so
what
flv exporter again i think fl i know
we're we're deprecating the export but
we're keeping
now we have the ability to import which
is going to continue to be relevant
because people are continually going to
continue to have flash files
um okay now okay you're suggesting we
add flv to dollar import formats then
that's what i'm suggesting
most i'll have to check if uh it goes
through um
perhaps we can register it okay um if
there is any technical issues i'll let
you know okay
i guess we can do it
don't these zip ish files nowadays have
passwords
yes and where is that password
the plan is to put them on their
authentication option
because they may live on a server
and you may want to include a username
and password for this well yeah
right what you want to be able to do is
to use the um
uh system credentials exactly right
so an authentic authentication arrow the
the main authentication option
supported here right not yet
okay but it will yes
what is the file extension for this
facebook compression thing
zsdd well then that's what we should
call this don't call it z standard just
call it
i mean standard is is just call it the
std
just like every other format we have
the the format is still called z
standard i don't care look
we're naming all these things by the
essentially by their file extension
let's just follow that cstd
okay all caps
well what's everything else done i mean
jpeg is not all caps always
well the the way we register the format
is all caps jpeg i guess the sddl caps
is gonna be fine
yeah i think it's fine you can have z
standard as an alternate if you want to
sure
data set export to these what about data
set import we've had that already we had
that yeah this
what about our project to dramatically
speed up these imports
for excellence the csv discussion
yes um
not for 12 2 but we are looking at well
we did some some benchmarks some timings
for csv
to me that's an important thing right
xls is yeah i understand xls is already
fast
csv uh is the one that we questioned in
the
mailing list discussion
okay all right well fine but it needs
the all of those
basic formats need to be very fast okay
why is protobuf internal only
we can't make it it's just extra work to
make it external
get it registered and all of that we can
make it uh you should i think it's
useful
yep fine not 12-2 i suppose but yeah
what we can put it on the list
right ben on the live stream is thanking
you for data set export in xls
ian livestream is saying that speeding
up csv import will be great
um okay
have i looked at the threat analysis for
mbox before
you have but unfortunately i think this
is another one that has to wait until
post 12 too
but the elements we discussed in
i i don't know maybe an lccc
okay what what is this also planned for
12-2 this is just
other other stuff that may make it matte
importer may make it into 12 to open exr
uh okay let's go look at
file format though import with url you
don't need to look at file format is
getting a second argument which
yeah so again file format new
is the one you want to look at
all right second argument what is it
doing
this is mainly for significant speed
improvement
um current file format no second
argument has to go through 200 formats
to check if it's one of the formats that
we have registered
if you give it a single product or a
list of formats
we just check for those and return those
that match
fine or you return a failure object if
it doesn't and none
currently
i wonder whether in this case here you
should return a failure object
and what about the third syntax
in the third syntax you really want a
list of format
eyes that match
if none of the match you're saying you
would return a null list or whatever
um
currently we return none in both cases
if there is no match
i don't think that's quite right because
i think this case you're
checking is this compatible with this
format before you read it in
but it's not still returning a boolean
it returns
format if it matches is is this a jpeg
it
kind of it returns jpeg again yeah
all right we had an internal file format
queue
that we wanted to bring up to system and
we thought this might be
an okay alternative
i i mean i'm wondering why file format
queue isn't the better thing because
it's uh
you know the code is going to be cleaner
that way
file format queue of source comma format
true false and in this case here
is this really a thing
it's really useful to say is this an
image format
is this one of jpeg png gif
well but that i think is a different
question that's again maybe a file
format queue you're right i think so
which is which is
file format queue of source comma quotes
image or source comma
the the the actual symbol image
is this an image format
i think file format queue is a better
idea than this
now if you scroll down to examples there
are examples where we have
gzipped files that one you have under
the format sub section
it is a gzip it is also a 3ds
fine
that's fine because if i said import of
this as a 3ds it would work right
the importer knows to go through the
gzip
it does yes yes okay that's fine then i
think that's okay i think it should be
file format cue
now here
i don't mind this case here
right
and the singleton version of that
would then just return a null list if it
doesn't match
right the singleton version of that
would be equivalent to a single
singleton list here
okay makes sense and then you still want
a
file format queue i do that yeah i think
it's useful
i think it's successful with a with the
second argument that can be things like
image
graph graphics whatever
oh you i okay that that's gonna that
that's gonna be a bigger project you
want format categories in a sense
yeah yeah i mean you don't have to get
that for 12 too
and i don't think there might be also
formats that
live in very many categories but yeah
okay
okay okay we can look at it all you're
asking is is it
importable as an image with the image
element
yep yeah i understand
um sandra is asking why not true false
with several association i don't think
it's necessary i think you can just map
over the thing it's gonna
it's gonna try it in all these different
ways anyway it's not it's not doing
anything
magical right it's not it's not got a
giant finite state machine where it's
testing off many things in parallel
right um
okay there's a question here about
spatial formats shapefiles and geojson i
think we have
shapefiles in geojson um
but that's not this meeting roger can
you confirm that
uh yes we do and we're it's not for 12.2
but we have been gearing
up for kind of a major push on the geo
formats
um so i think
hopefully the the version after 12.2
will see a major uptick
and update both okay okay
ali is asking what's after 12 2 is it 12
3 or 13
that's a good question it's a good
question yes
um the question here from tz or xml
imports requiring xsd schema
i don't know what that completely means
i don't know
um okay
i mean we we have that okay let's go to
the rest of the agenda here
um i know with file format what was the
thing that we were doing with machine
learning and so on
with with file formats was that oh no
that was for that was for
um character encodings
there's a question here are step files
supported i don't know what those are
um it's coming um this it may make it
for 12
2. they are they are cad formats
okay they're sort of geometric cad so
um it's a very rich format actually um
okay where did we get to last time and
going through this
you looked at most of the video
functions um
and skim through audio and image okay
let's look at
okay so and we i got convinced last time
about this video generator name
i really would like to actually well i
think i got convinced i'd really like to
try it a bit
but we're not going to have time for
that today um
these are the names we discussed last
time right mm-hmm yes
i it's the names we discussed or not
here
i guess we say record so the animation
the animation object um
animated image where do we have that oh
there we go animated
one second before we we get there for
video um the video the track selections
you suggested we call them video track
selection
audio track selection and so forth i
think that's fine
we didn't finalize how we're gonna save
a video that has some selection options
in it
into a new video um
the team thinks that it's not necessary
event to do to
to get that export and import workflow
might be just fine
but if you really want a function that
does that
hold on so that's that's if once i've
made a selection
save only save the selection which is
only
a piece of metadata effectively on top
of the the actual video right
correct so the issue is if i
if i put a bunch of edit marks into my
video
do i maintain those edit marks for the
next time i come back or do i have to
redo them
i'd really like to maintain the edit
marks why can't i
maintaining a sense to actually i don't
think you file
hold on just to be on the right same
page
the discussion we had last time so the
thing is that videos can come with
multiple
video tracks multiple audio tracks and
multiple subtitle tracks
and so the selections basically pick
which one
because the workflow that streamlined
workflow we've made is sort of you pick
one video one audio one subtitle
you don't you don't we don't do sort of
the multi
multi version you know generally
speaking
you pick one for what purpose for doing
a video map or something
yes if you do video map you know you
pick the first one
or the one that's selected by the way
has it your technology that's being used
here to do those video frame lists that
are now
in i don't know whether they're yet
deployed but but um
that are coming is was that done with
with all this stuff
i think so i see if i can even find one
let's see if it's here
um that's not yet here
uh it's very beautiful very very
beautiful
what are you guys talking about uh live
stream
livestream archive summaries oh yeah
i'll show you this have you seen that
roger no i haven't just let me try and
pull one up here
um
where is it where is it where is it um
oh it's here why is why am i not finding
it look at this isn't this cool
yeah it's pretty super useful
that's stupid but that's okay um
and has some kind of mechanism here for
for scrolling through it i don't know
whether this is a standard
thing that we're providing for the
scroll through
and then when you click on this it will
go to the appropriate place in the
youtube video
oh isn't that super cool
it is super cool we should provide some
way to actually export
this kind of this exact object so that
people can do this
at least a function repository function
to do that
yeah that actually reminds me of other
features too but
um yeah
so so so the discussion we had last time
was that we wanted these options you
know for you to point to be able to sort
of point to that
um but then you said but how do i
how do i get rid of all the other things
how do i make it
a video with only those things in with
the other things removed
is how i understood your question well
hold on a second so so what is the thing
we're saying we're saying
these are video tracks is an option
yes which selects which tracks i want to
be talking about
in this video right yes
yes okay so now what is the question so
so the question was
you said but you said i don't want the
options there i want it to sort of
be converted to a video with only those
things in it
and so we said well you you don't need
to but you can
you can always do export and import and
you you didn't like that
particularly um and the question is how
often do you need to do that or want to
do that
operation sorry just one second i was
looking at a calendar thing here
oh by the way uh um
internal person says uh
it's on like avery who's on the live
stream says that
um comments that they used form pages to
generate the html code
for all of the pods that we have here
that's that's very cool nice
the so it's really dog food all the way
yes it's full dog food the
um okay
okay sorry could you repeat what you
were saying i i lost track
so to speak um okay so the operation so
given a video object
with these options set does there need
to be
a separate function that converts it to
a video object without
any of those options i see where it's
been burnt in
yes i thought we had some whole burning
mechanism and what happens
when you give a video selection right
i mean if i do a video split i will
actually get
what do i get i can actually get it you
know it
doesn't store it it's not lazy you know
it's not lazy store it and then sort of
replace it
the general principle is if it's a noun
it's lazy if it's a verb it just does it
right really we don't really have any
lazy i mean
okay you don't have lazy stuff here you
have but but this means
it's still pointing to the same video
file but it's saying
it's got something on top of it that
says we're only we're taking this part
of the video file is that correct
video split is actually going to write
the content into
new files okay fine and new set up okay
so so then all of those things do that
yeah all of those things do that all of
those but the selections don't
where are the selected
options yes
well how do i get just the first how do
i get look
if i want the audio from the video i say
audio of the video object is that oh
yeah
yes okay if i want track 7 but i don't
want track 2
what do i do video
uppercase video of your video object
comma video tracks goes to 7.
or video track selection okay so no no
video
tracks right or is it video tracking
it's video tracks now but you're
suggesting
a rename to track selection for all of
this yes i i think so
yes please change it to track selection
otherwise it's the wrong thing otherwise
it's it's
um okay so what you're saying is you can
get
just that by saying video of
the video comma video track
selection arrow seven for example right
yes yes and now this is gonna be lazy
yeah but my request was to make a
non-lazy version of this
right right do we actually need that
no i don't care i mean you tell you know
i'll i'll care if people like avery come
back and say they're burning
huge amounts of disk space on things
that don't make any sense but
absent that i i don't care okay okay
that's good because that's we spent a
lot of time in the team discussing it
and we couldn't figure out why we need
it
okay terrific i'm i'm not going to push
it
okay we can always get it later if we
just get all right
yes okay that's what i'm suggesting
generated data destination
again the name is not something that
internally is being liked
i don't know if you want to rediscuss
the name this one yep
well i'm sorry we're not this was about
many different things right
yes if somebody's got a better
suggestion that fits all those
objectives then we'll listen to it right
no well no
i i don't think i think it rolls off
your tongue
it's it's listen it rolls in what sense
i don't know
but but uh
it's a little difficult yes but but it's
okay because it's a very internal thing
and um uh you know i think here
um yeah tag it is experimental okay
okay so we need to change it um
oh yeah this is an interesting one from
sando what about a video compose
analogous to image compose like adding a
logo to a video
that's gonna go on their video frame map
where you can frame by frame burn
something into frames
i see so it will be an image composed
frame by frame
yes i i thought about how much of these
video functions that do something frame
by frame we want and i think
at least the way to go 12-2 is to have
this generic
mapping filtering functions um
yeah i think it's right for now and if
it turns out there's something that's
just a
really common thing to want to do um we
will get it later
right okay uh
yeah i see is
suggesting a track selection arrow video
r01 audio
two i don't think so quite because i
think that that's going to be
that you can get multiple video tracks
and all kinds of crazy things like that
um okay where do we go next what's this
video confirm
properties that's that's the conform
images conform
audio analog um
wait a minute that's conform conform
yeah okay okay so that that that's the
analog
of what other functions conform audio
and conform images
i i explained last time conforming video
is some
known term when you run your prototype
or your workflow
on door resolution video and then you
want to
do the same operation on full resolution
that process is called conforming
the video basically conforming the whole
process that you have defined
on the full resolution what does this do
what does conform video properties do
um this is just gonna make properties of
a
list of video objects conform so all
the same raster size all the same frame
rate and so forth
sorry sorry say that again what you're
gonna conform your video objects to have
similar properties such as
same raster size same frame rate
and why is that different from what you
said when you said
you know take the edited thing at low
resolution and
and apply that editing to the higher
resolution thing
is that that why is that so different
from this operation
the this operation is defined on
multiple videos that you would like to
make
similar to have similar problems but
okay
the other one is a unary operation where
it's saying in a sense i've got this
template video
that's low resolution edited video with
certain certain metadata on it
and i want to apply that metadata to the
full resolution video right
okay so i don't understand why that's
such a different operation
doesn't seem that different i mean it's
or more unidirect i mean it's like you
want to take from the low to high
a particular thing so when you give
several images or several
audio and so on there's a certain
standardization that's
applied you know which which direction
things coerce or conform
and it's not necessarily like the first
one
applies to all the later ones um
by the way ali on our live stream is is
saying awesome stuff to shoddy
for this video i think good um
but i'm also not sure do you i mean last
time we discussed this we were sort of a
little bit unsure whether we know what
conform video is going to
need to do yet as far as defaults
okay so so flip on our live stream who i
know knows lots about video
is commenting that the the terminologies
can form the video from
proxy apparently the proxy is the
low-res form
right so in other words what that is is
it's taking
um and uh um
um
uh
let's see yeah i mean
i don't understand so first of all let's
take conform image
conform images is that right conform
images
what does that do it takes a list of
images
and it makes them it conforms them all
to what
same size same and i understand that but
to what does it what does it use as the
template
as far as well you can specify in the
spec
what you want to get back but by default
as
as for bit depth and color space we get
the largest
common or the smallest common property
for the size it's a median computation
we don't get the largest we get some
median size
all right so one of the possibilities
would be
you've got a spec argument here why not
have something where you say conform
video and you've got the video
that you're trying to conform and the
proxy
the proxy is the spec in other words use
a video as the spec and here
for the spec argument what are you what
are you able to use for the spec
argument why don't you just be able to
put an image as the spec argument here
and then you've got something consistent
um is it isn't that the first one in the
first table
oh yes it is
the way i understand conforming from a
proxy is that you have a process that
you would
like to run so it's kind of a conform
video
video comma filter graph or video come
up you know the whole
pipeline the function not video comma
proxy
i see
yeah flip is commenting and video
editing there's usually a project
setting for the full resolution which is
what you're basically saying
yeah um
uh yeah i am interested here the the um
i just some comments on a live stream
from ali talking about
uh uh
promoting our image stuff but
complaining that graphs can be improved
out we'd like to hear what we what you
think can be improved with graphs
and um uh yeah we're working on
computational geometry
um valued customer interesting name is
um talking about image related
functionality hoping for performance
improvements with listanimate i believe
that's what animated image is supposed
to do
animated image should be the
dramatically i mean
but between video and animated image
okay explain the difference between
animated image and video
the current version of animated image is
all in core
uh we can't have an we can eventually
have an out of core version of that i
i guess we should hit wait until front
end has
library link support so that for display
purposes we just send data directly
from the file to the front end rather
than it routed through the kernel
sorry for which but for for animated
image animated image
so the prototype for animated image
right now is actually using dynamics
it's not
the spiffy thing that we expect to have
eventually right what is the what is the
time frame for libra link in the front
end
um john says 12-2 we're gonna get it but
towards the end of the cycle
i doubt we can build an efficient video
gui or anything else
um with that 412.
but that you know anything okay but that
will come soon thereafter right
so we can have an experimental animated
image as an experimental thing in 12 2.
where in particular we can take animated
image of a gif file yes
yes or animated png and so on
yeah that's really useful it's really
useful that's a much more lightweight
version of um
uh so the way that we specify this
animated image of file of
such and such dot gif yes eventually yes
currently it's animated image of
import of file which gives you a list of
images
back so it's animated image of list of
images
it's documented if you want to look at
i think we should support the pure file
case even though it's it's
doing something rather uninteresting
right now okay
and import the file the the frame sure
i think we should do that yeah you
should say animated image of a file
sure okay
um
[Music]
and you say experimental until it has
proper file support than
type setting i think so what's what's
wrong with its type setting
well but what i was saying it could get
faster
yep doesn't it have a dynamic now
yeah okay fine but it does have a stop
button and things like that so that's
not
oh yeah we built that on top of dynamic
but but it will be guaranteed spiffy i
wonder whether that's
yeah i understand i wonder whether the
idea of a stop button like that is
useful for dynamics in general
i wonder whether it should be an option
to dynamic to put that to include that
in the dynamic rendering
i think it should be should talk to john
about that
might not be clear where to put it
stephen it can be anywhere on the whole
notebook
where would you put what do you mean no
i mean
dynamic you me yeah dynamic i'm talking
about any dynamic
i'm saying that any dynamic would have a
pause button on it
could just be very small that the object
itself yeah
i understand it could be small in which
case it is what it is right
i think it's a good idea i think it
would be a good uh you know
it would prevent a bunch of crazy
dynamics that are just burning through
cpu doing nothing useful
should i pass it on to john please okay
i think it would also be interesting if
switching off dynamics disabling
dynamics caused all of the dynamics to
have those stop buttons on them
that's probably something for when we
have a notebook toolbar right
well we already have you know in the
evaluation stop stop dynamics yes
so my suggestion would be to bring up if
you stop dynamics that every dynamic
gets a pause button in it
and then you want something globally for
a notebook
that pause or stop all done all dynamics
there already is yeah there's already
the polls
kill all of the dynamics can we pause
them wouldn't that be more useful
yes it would be more useful it would be
so i think you should show this to john
suggest a pause dynamics suggest
possibly changing
the dynamic disabled i mean dynamic
disabled is the same as pausing the
dynamics
but what i'm saying is dynamic disabled
in the menu should cause all the
dynamics to display
maybe with a with a pause button on them
so that you can re-enable one at a time
so you're not if there's one dynamic
that's burning everything right
that you just disable everything and you
go back and you re-enable
the dynamic you actually want to see
yep okay so
uh some questions on our live stream
here from sander
what does video resample do if you go
from 24 frames per second to 25.
there are there are basically resampling
frame rate
change algorithms simplest ones are
taking near as neighbors
but there are interpolation routines as
well many methods proposed in literature
we're going to be having the simplest 1
12 2
but it could be extended with a method
option later on so basically it's going
to just work
as the basic point okay
um
a question from on over here why not
annotated gifts which allow tunneling to
other gifts on the go what is an
annotated gif
i don't know do you know what that is
shoddy yeah
we should look it up don't know
um
uh let's see there's a question here
about
i just have to respond to which is it's
about um
pan and zoom for 2d plots can we demo it
and do you know is it working here yet
it's coming in twelve two
um i don't know whether it's working
here
nope nothing interesting there will be
is that with the toolbar
yeah it's with the toolbar who's working
on that
noah perhaps noah is working on the
drawing toolbar um
this is a oh gosh it's come out of the
john
pasey brett effort
that initially was in the cloud it was
first implemented in the cloud
okay now you should check into it i mean
i
i think it's i think it's on course who
knows what these are
okay let's go back over here so i want
to talk through this thing about
about um projects video projects and so
on
okay so
uh and this question about video conform
so let me understand the issue so i mean
a very you're saying
that i'm i'm actually really confused
all around
okay if i say video trim video whatever
video
all these things these are not lazy they
just get done
right yes so how am i
storing i don't have a good way because
they're not lazy
i don't have a good way to store my
sequence of operations that i did on the
proxy video
that i can then apply to the full video
so what's the right way to handle that a
filter graph
and that's not going to be a 12 2. well
what does it mean what does it mean what
is a filter
it's just a directly dicyclic graph that
says
do these operations and they can depend
on each other
but i don't understand that's a look
it's like a neural net framework or
something where we have
a whole you know mechanism for
representing
a series of operations that are done you
know uh
with with neural net layers and that's
an alternative to actually having a
program you know f of g of
h of x it's this you know
you know it's this thing where we
basically have a list of layers what are
you talking about here
well a dag or a filter graph is a
program
um that has understand this is a general
issue i mean
i understand but this is a general issue
that if we have you know
f of g of h you know
and and we're going to be you know
whatever it is i don't know what the
thing would be right composition of this
of x or something ah that's not what i
wanted
oh i see i don't need those
right things like that um
but i'm confused um but it's a little
bit more complicated right because
the the um none of these sort of
composition functions
deal with multivariate functions in a
significant way
no i understand that we we've done this
in the neural net framework it's a
complicated hairy mess right and and
what we've done here
you know is nice functional you know
function based
operations sure and i'm i'm confused
about i mean i don't understand i don't
think we have a
a striking design to look at at this
point
i want because what we could have is a
pure function i mean essentially this is
like compilation
in some sense you're gonna you're gonna
build up a pure function
you're going to okay you're gonna do a
bunch of things in your notebook
blah blah blah blah right then you're
going to want to say but actually i want
to apply
things on lines 12 to 17 i want to
package them all together
and i want to apply them to my full
resolution video
right so i would argue that the right
way to do that
is to have a suggestions bar type thing
that picks up all those pieces that you
put on lines 12 through 17
packages them together and gives you
back a pure function
which you then apply to the full video
and then you're not changing any
operations here you're just doing the
exact same things we already have
am i confused
no the the
the thing that we can do i think we need
i mean i understand what you're saying
and it doesn't seem like a bad idea to
sort of play this
you know make it a playable thing but
for filter graphs particularly in audio
and i think video two we have sort of
the notion of them working in real time
which means that they're going to do a
little bit of operations
um at a time yes because some systolic
type thing
in some sense yeah okay
but all right look look this is a
general issue i mean
both that you know that the dynamic
aspect of this
and you know in the neural net case we
are right now
even as we speak unpacking from this
layer-based graph based
thing to turn it into something more
like a functional program
i i know right so i mean it's like
what we need what this is a kind of
duality between the graph based thing
and the functional programming
thing and there's other places where we
want to be able to display a functional
program as a graph
right and you know we've just got this
duality between these things and i think
we need a general way to deal with this
yeah yeah i mean there's more
you know and bdds are dags and so on and
we have other sort of dag
expression representations right um well
like a graph i mean the fact is we can't
take a graph
you know which happens to be a dag and
say execute this we have expression
graph now
but we don't have graph we have
expression graph
which goes from an expression to a graph
we don't have go from a graph to an
expression
right we and maybe we should have no i
mean we could i mean
it's you can't do that with every graph
but you need something there to actually
do
it's a it's a particular application a
graph it's a particular style of network
right um let's let's have a separate
meeting about this about the duality
between graph languages and
um functional languages okay and and in
terms of this photograph thing
i i think that needs to be in there
um okay
honor is saying annotation is done via
hover on buttons
when the interaction loop pauses to an
observer to read details within an
annotation i see
weird all right okay so this is
something to do with animated gifs which
i'm not familiar with in this case
i'll look into it um
right fine okay uh
what's next here so we're still talking
about conform video
and i'm trying to understand what it is
and explain to me what conform video
properties was supposed to be
the conform video properties is really
going to be the analog
of our conform images conform audio
yeah and just just to be safe to not use
a
function name like conform video for
something that is going to be doing
something
else or need to be doing something else
so we're just going to stick it into
video context for 12.2
all right fine if somebody needs it we
can come back to
one conform video later okay
fine okay next
video frame map that's mapping frame by
frame right
and this is gonna be useful for say
blending video one into
video two once we get multiple video
objects right or this thing about
putting a
you know a watermark on the video or
something that that can already be done
with a version that is in twelve one
okay oh i see but but without
conformance
we can't get the the frames to agree
okay
video time series um so what is that
doing that that's
that's taking video with a with a known
time
and it's saying at the five minute mark
put a big red blob
blob on it that type of thing is that
correct no it outputs non-video it
outputs
oh that's right yeah i remember what it
is yes
okay video the idea is that the 12-2
update if you scroll down to my
tentative notes
is gonna take into account audio um or
time as well so you can do computations
based on it's kind of like
map index version when time is included
as well
and so what was the thing before it was
just an
it was just the frames it was just the f
f
the function f was just getting video
frames one at a time or another time
it's getting an association with but how
can that be compatible
with what with what it was doing before
the
one arc form the slot is gonna be the
image
can we do that
is that done lexically or how does that
work we can
look at audio block map i think that's
doing the same thing
but how does it work does it in terms of
internally how does it work is it is it
how does it know that it was given a
slot
i mean by the do you understand what i'm
asking
other than my lexical means
[Music]
i suspect it can't know unless it does a
test
yeah that's what i think too
right this seems rather hokey to me i
mean this is kind of like handler
functions what are you going to give me
oh actually yeah now i remember if you
scroll down i think we are suggesting
something like a handler function keys
to be included there as well
i don't i don't have it here
well i'd be okay with that if you can
use this as a heuristic with an
automatic setting but you can give it a
handler function
i mean it's not handler function some
other keys
thing that needs to be given yeah
now what is the chunk of audio
how big a chunk um corresponding to
one frame or n frames
how do you specify the n um in the as
the third
argument of the function oh i see that's
the
that's but but that's in a sense that
duration right no i understand but hash
image is just a single image at a time
isn't it
um but but if you have n hash image is
going to be a list of images
a list of n images okay but if you if
you have
no n specified there how big is the
audio chunk
corresponding the the samples
corresponding to one frame
i see so it's 125th of a second or
something like that
yeah of audio yep okay
um okay
so video map
now time series is limiting in a sense
that the
result has to have matching dimensions
all the way through so if you ask for
dominant colors
of all frames since one image may have
one frame may have two dominant colors
the other one could have ten
you cannot put them into a time series
oh yes so we kind of
wait wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute yes you can the time series
values should just be lists
it can't be double this but there is
character you can put them
in it just won't work um well i
understand that it works
no i understand the time so for instance
the signal processing functions from
shoddy they don't know how to deal with
varying dimensions
no i understand that point i understand
that point
okay but that's okay given that even the
construct
returns a failure if you say time series
yeah if if if you have lists of
variables
then it's wrong it should be able to
store that stuff and you know some
operations should be able to work on it
probably not i mean that's this that's
i mean if we want a very general object
like that it will be kind of not due
very much
but we could build an object like that
it was inconsistent with value
dimensions arrow one
well whatever okay i mean i know we're
overhauling time series anyway so
i'm not sure um oh that's the new date
formatting that's nice
i except i i thought we were making the
time zone smaller
can can somebody make a note here time
zone should be smaller and the period
should be removed from the time zone
yep thanks
um so so what's the issue here so
so this question needs to be a vector
space you know if you want to
all right okay fine all right i'm i'm
okay with that for the time being
um okay now the question is that can we
introduce a video map
that returns a list of results instead
of a time series of results okay what do
we have in terms of audio we don't have
audio map do we
what do we have audio local measurements
which gives a time series as well
which has the same limitation
okay wait a minute okay video frame map
video frame map maps a function over
frames in the video
returning a list of results doesn't it
returning a list of images which goes
into a new video
video frame map is a video to video
operation
i see
so this is something where you want to
get out
a time series of what i'm the sort of
time series a list
of associations which have time stamps
in them or what what comes out
for the video no just the values of the
function by
frame by frame but frame by frame right
yes maybe it should be called
i mean the other thing is called video
frame list isn't it the thing which
gives a list of images
from the video right it's called video
frame list
correct yes so why don't we call it
video frame list map
which is the analog of finding video
frame list
for every frame and just saying map on
that
which is what it is right
are you gonna remember which one is
which video
frame map video frame list map
i think so okay i mean it's a it's it's
mapping onto a list of frames
as opposed to mapping onto the video
mapping onto the frames in the video
i don't like video map i really don't
like video map video map will be the one
i would think would be video to video
because map after all just does its
business insider
inside an expression and returns the
expression
um i still find our names function names
a little confusing here
i as you see i have name well
all of them image it video frame list
video video frameless doesn't seem
confusing to me
that's that's not video extract frame is
another one that's not confusing
um no mainly these four that we have
here
and two of them are just proposed for 12
too if you can sort these out
i understand
i think video frame map is okay
i really don't mind video frameless map
what does video filter do
that's also supposed to be a video to
video where you take into account
audio timestamp subtitle track data as
well
why on earth can't that be done in video
frame map
we could do it just that video frame map
sounds like a frame to frame
it sounds like it's just image input
rather than image audio
subtitle input and how does it get is it
getting that input the same way that
video time series gets the input
yep
well i have to say i would have thought
flip is suggesting video map maps
look i would suggest if this is really
the way you want to go
is what is when you map onto a time
series what do we call it we call it
time series map don't we
um yes i think
i think it's called moving map though we
also have time series map
yeah which maps onto a time series
okay i'm gonna make a suggestion okay
that this thing is strictly mapping onto
individual frames video time series map
does that
and maybe video map
does your do everything video filter
thing
which can take you know all the
different hash
pieces
maybe which one was video time series
math
the one that's currently called video
time series
and the one and video frame map
would be one that specifically maps
frame by frame
i'm not sure that we have to have i
think it's okay to have video frame map
even though it can you know take
fragments of audio as well
because i think it's okay
to do that i see it i think because
you're saying we
the still the unit of chunk is a frame
yes that's what i'm saying yes okay okay
now
i mean returning a list okay so this so
the only other case is this is video to
video
okay this returns a video right
yes video time series map returns a time
series yes
i guess we could still call it video
time series
if it's if it's going to continue
returning a time series well this is
returning the time series that's what it
does
yep and then we want a version that
returns a list
i see i like that well
that would have to be the combination
there video map
which i don't like very much i think
that's obscure
that returns a video
video map list which return a list
see we can't really call it video frame
map even though i would like to call it
that because otherwise we're going to
end up with video frame map time series
maybe we should end up with that
maybe that's the least obscure thing to
do
video frame map time series
or maybe all video maps are on frames
you know chunks of time chunks no but it
bothers me because i mean we're not
how does it agree with other things like
video replace or something
i guess that's okay with that
um
ah let's see
yeah there's people saying that's a
ridiculous mouthful and they're right
well so your your basic claim is video
map
see we've decided on video frame list
it's not called video list
yep
and i like video framelits i think it's
clear what it does
okay so the proposal will be video map
time series video map list and video map
it's not terrible
let's try it okay let's try going with
that
they they all at least start from that's
it's a good family video map family
yeah okay uh anything else we need to
cover
and video frame list sorry video frame
map
is going away it's going away that
becomes video map
yep
yeah so just to be clear i mean we
should be able to do
video map time series of facial
you know of the face recognition thing
that should all
just work right should return
lists of different lengths again
but it depends what you return you could
return it as an image
i guess you see what i'm saying i mean
in um
look let me give you an example date
list plot
let's say we want to get a picture
that shows the faces in a video
as a function of the time in the video
what's the minimum path to getting that
we're going to get
each i mean there's a little bit of
arbitrariness because you've got to
see how you stack i mean that's an
interesting
um visualization thing
is you know i'm sure dateless plot
well that's really yeah it's complicated
because it's going to involve
intervals and things like this we're not
quite i mean it's going to require a
little bit of code still
okay what's next here video position and
video intervals
kind of related to what you were going
where you were going
where you can ask you you get back
positions or intervals
of interesting stuff in the video what's
the analog what's image position what
does it do
it returns pixel positions yes
just raw pixel position so video
position here
does it refer type return times or frame
counts frame numbers
times why
what else how do i how do i get a
particular video
frame extract extract frames
gets times as well by default if you pas
give it a number
it is it assumes it's it's a time
in seconds but you can also give it
quantity and video position is going to
return back quantities as well
i i guess it could do quantity array
probably should but i video position
returning quantities is really weird
um
i mean unless i can go and say video
part extract or something like that
something or another
position bothers me there
are something that sort of says time
event
you know like i think they're called
time codes often in video but
that's not going to use that but
bob is asking is the image recognition
stuff available in raspberry pi i think
so for robots yeah i think so i think
people use it there i think they have
done for some time actually
video frame apply
bob suggests a dog food action which is
feed this video stream that we are
making right now
uh enter wolfram language and
extract all the notebooks
yeah interesting test i don't know the
image processing to do with extracting
these
rectangular regions would be interesting
not undoable
all right so anyway i'm sorry we're back
to
okay so
hold on video position
right what is it supposed to return
again
of the same kind used in the in the
uh x coordinates of time series is that
correct
yes yes okay so i wanted to take so just
so i understand
if i took video position as you
currently
call it
i think it should be something say
something about times in the name
i just don't think position is the right
thing to call it
well okay when you say video insert what
what units are you using how are you
inserting
is it by yeah any any scalar provided to
these functions
as time is assumed to be in seconds
how do i give it frames instead um
quantity number comma frames
which is an independent unit okay
do we think that's okay have you tried
using this yep
but it's okay it's
i don't know how else we could have done
it
it's really useful to assume as scalar
as the time because videos can have
different
frame rates you don't want to constantly
compute the number of frame you would
you're interested in doing something
with
and also when people point something out
in a video yeah
look at look at time code blah blah blah
right i'm gonna have to run off here
we're almost done but we're not quite
this requires a little bit more
discussion i think
i think that this position thing should
be
um what do we call it for audio shoddy
um audio intervals we have but we don't
have the event
no i see
i think we could do video time position
or positions
and video time intervals just to make it
explicit
i don't think video that wouldn't hurt
okay but i mean
okay various people flip is mentioning
that time code means generic times used
in video
event lists or edls edit decision lists
apparently time codes with things
attached
okay
uh we should look up edit decision lists
apparently there's some standardization
of them
also being suggested by ic is um
video region which would be
i'm not sure i'm not sure which of these
that will be i mean that's more like an
extract video what do we call it video
frame extract
extract frames video extract frames
i'd like to rethink that particular one
because i mean video intervals should be
returning things that you can feed into
video extract frames
right does it uh it returns beginning
and
end of any interval video extract frame
if you give it those two times give you
those
two frames at the beginning and then
listen we need to talk about this okay
can you can you
lead that um
yeah flip is pointing out audio events
and video events are interesting
concepts
we don't understand those um we need to
come back and look at this some more and
i unfortunately have to go
um we're really close we'll need one
more i think
iteration on this but we're a lot of
wonderful functionality
do you agree one more one more iteration
here probably got a few more things to
pull together i think so
one more and you feel it will feel baked
okay and i would like to next time
uh let's just do one more pass on video
generator and so on
okay okay excellent stuff
see you all thank you very much people
on the live stream a lot of great
comments
um